I'm away takeaways can't wait hi bro
can't watch time not up in here here we
gotta go we gotta go I'm telling you
right now gotta go yeah I'm getting
emotional right now me too I feel like
crying I just need answers man I don't
know here we go again oh well Brennan
we're not with Fox anymore this official
response without in my hand we're off
the old corporate teat get your tit out
of my memoir no one no more suits with
tits yeah but just like Rogan does Adam
Carolla I'm Garen you look at these
hugely successful podcasts no one's
really under the umbrella of corporate
but we were under contract until August
2017 so we thought I saw ya hit him with
the truth we didn't want the truth so we
thought we were in a contract till
August 2017 and then we because we did
this TV deal there was a loophole
because it was all packaged in the past
so if I'm killed as a package deal with
podcasts personalities on Fox and TV
show so it was all in one so if one of
those well ours our agents are mafia bad
ass asians say those guys know the
business and they went well there's a
little loophole here I went home stop I
thought it says it can you edit this
here's why went you can't have Brian
Santa because it makes me look bad haha
I think it's all getting all the fans
with your insights on the studio we
literally just program the studio
yesterday and the cameras everything I
see you guys who have the problem with
the way the Fox setup was we're getting
that fixed I'm building a literally
building Brian just found out we broke
ground today as he walked in take out
video granted that i posted is funny but
it's honest you had no idea who won that
fight Chandler won it and he ddt'd
suplex been and it's something to see
I'm have to show it cuz your balls deep
and guys doing stuff like that girl is
on this grand watch admit males and you
know I was a wrestler there are a lot of
people that are disenfranchised in this
country there are a lot of people are
looking Hillary I mean look at what
Hillary said she said their deplorable
no no that that's how when I'm talking
about been there a terrible under starts
with D I know but a lot of a lot of
syllables a lot gay everybody loves my
vocabulary no why have some of the best
Silla
stop the only real American here yeah
you are a real art I'm looks great but
um kick-out you know if there's one
thing I do it's take a good punch to the
face I'm excited for this one I'm like
right the [ __ ] is going on my TV right
now yeah baby it doesn't matter if it's
Chicago Illinois New York City or
richmond virginia who the fords made
daddy they collect a fav dude yeah
brother yeah okay Fabe dude it's like
when I used to cut my promos dude let me
tell you something brother wife and that
Andre the Giant down for worse the fries
out 71 hockey I rock maniacs dude you
know we're going for you see a wet
kayfabe man like he's by going through
some stuff and if I guess big boy knows
him because if you know Kanye this like
something's going on man like
something's wrong with me pregnant at
auxonne like this isn't typical car like
he eat us rants with the canceled and
bail on people crazy it's not a
breakdown he's out in the britney spears
moment like he's easy to shave his head
and just freaked out show up in a fur
coat or some [ __ ] I didn't off la sienna
yes you won like lipo tiggles face
everything in an office place they had
an honor system where you would take a
bagel or a doughnut and you would put
money like they'd say you know thanks
have my grocery stores with candy 25
cents but some money and I got like six
put the five cents I was seven yes put
some money in there you can when you get
the doughnuts and bagels you can get
more than one right and what I want so
the bottom lines wanted saying is that
you essentially are very influenced by
how you hold your body and what you see
from everything yeah that's why there's
marketing and corrected in colors that's
why it's how they look like yeah when
you go into Starbucks everything's the
same there's a smell there's the light
yes like your body reacts certain things
yes like when I see will I want to punch
him in the face hey man that's not cool
saying why would you say you know it
punched me in the face when you see me
that's terrible beretta will you defend
me because yeah I got you will what what
you do is you just take a rock
medium-sized we're on the gas put it on
the gas get into the back bed does the
battery so dangerous what the area that
I grew up in out in the country oh so
you just roll what are you gonna do hit
a fence you might stop I don't know if
you bump into a cow the cow you might
even roll over me or to me why it can be
mall me
you have the cow off meanwhile you what
you're nuts too but in the back yeah I'm
not to [ __ ] anus in the back that's
what's up in the back end what I mean
currency there is like literally like
weed and booze fish than cash is like
number five all times then it's very
interested and happy in the [ __ ] nice to
do this cat you don't even know you know
as bit of a hater i'll be i was like
right the [ __ ] is this man i guess not
but not because of you I was like what
are we doing likes not very creative and
then I was going to switch this and then
you start saying some like funny stuff
link that's pretty funny then your shirt
was off like why I can dig that there's
uh you know lawyers like there's no
spectrum nurses everyone's using drugs
we're human I get a lot of messages on
facebook on my fan page on hook swear to
say fan page but the the you know it's
ripped like girlfriends boyfriends young
chefs older chefs reach out and they're
just like how do you do it how do you
how do you balance this stuff and it's
just like you just do it I wasn't I
wasn't like a bully bully where I'd like
chase people and like beat them up you
like just like pick on somebody like I
never had like one guy that I would
always pick on but like I think that
like you know I would like if somebody
like when I I got kicked out of one high
school grade 9 some dude like bumped
into me I like followed him into like a
room grabbed him just started like
punching him brought him outside in the
hallway like hit his head office saying
cases and it's just like she fighting
like you know everyone's watching like
worldstar I love watching world too I
got out the Worlds two worlds just
watchin dudes get [ __ ] Merc Merc
nobody knows what they want to do
finding that passion I am so happy and
grateful that I got to learn how to cook
and that I loved it but was it a fashion
absolutely I love going to restaurants
eating a restaurant snowed it is
perfectly average right now inch smaller
not an inch bigger again she deserves a
statue because you're this wild dude i'm
probably i'm sure you're working crazy
hours you had a heart attack next door
yeah say you have all these tattoo she's
and I guess have kids in your man yeah
she's the best oh you shop you got so
lucky man I'm like dude you know how
hard I've been grinding yeah I'll just
prepared for the opportunity when it
came yeah I think that that I think
taking the moments and turning them into
things and you know I'm a really strong
believer at a chef one time saying that
like yo we're giving you you know keys
and there's gonna be all these different
doors and you're gonna be able to open
up any door that you want if you keep
holding these keys and keep these keys
like clean you know it's just like you
need these tools and all this like noisy
when they go to Chicago yeah they call
it shy rack yeah I didn't know shy rack
was a bad term like it right I got
stylish Iraq hey I'm hip yeah and I was
doing a live comedy show with my partner
Brian at a sold-out theater in Chicago I
was like what's up Shadrach it went
terrible yeah it did not go good why a
chef weighs himself have no idea I don't
because I'm fat and you know I'm skinny
Maddie's not funny no I know skinny but
to 40 I'd still be I'd look real good
you're dying your dime piece at do 40 oh
dude we I call Youm Mabley grantees
Aryan have like titties